well it looks like we are now luck for
the first of the July philosophy pop-ups
this one is on as our topic will be for
the rest of the month Emily in
philosophical perspective and you might
say well why did he choose that theme
well my kids are here with me for this
entire month and you know I end up
thinking a bit about fatherhood and I
think about my my own family which is
quite a complicated things and adopted
and I'm in touch with both birth parents
and the families that result from them I
have five brothers one of whom I grew up
with who had no blood relation to at all
- half brother who's on one side and a
half brother and a half sister on the
other end so there's there's a lot of
complex connections there but as a
philosopher I've been thinking quite a
bit at you know for quite a long time
and about the family and it's an
important idea in social theory in
general and you know particularly and
quite a few of the authors who I work on
you know if you think about for example
the Aristotelian Tsar the Stoics or you
know and any of those sorts of
traditions family winds up playing an
important role and so it's I think it's
worth spending some time to talk about
and think about just what this construct
that we have is because a lot of people
treat family they were the sort of caddy
if it's like this automatic natural you
know building block of society and I
think you know to some extent the family
does and has function as a kind of
building block but never in quite so
clean away as its portrayed as being
it's always much messier than
a few people here's they hello so well
and and also make sure that everything
is going the way it's supposed to who
looking in the the chat chat area but
the control room since that that's how I
actually get access to my my chat
function but yeah let's talk a little
bit more about the the family itself and
and how it figures into early social
theory and philosophy and then I've got
a few remarks I wanted to say it just
drawn from from a few other philosophers
here and there so you know you see a
mate oh this this emphasis and it put it
put the Republic aside for a moment and
just think about all the other dialogues
and and what's going on within it and
how how important family is for all the
people who invoke at Socrates constantly
talking with fathers about how are they
educating their sons presumably there is
some attention to that being given at
least by the upper class there's you
know there's a lot of discussion about
what what we owe to each other how the
family to Aristotle you know Aristotle
begins the politics by talking about the
way Coast the household and he he tells
us that this is one of the things that
is by nature and and you know it is to
some degree right if we look at just
about every culture across the world we
have male-female coupling and children
being produced it's always within some
sort of cultural matrix once we get past
that's the level of whatever you want to
call like primitive human beings that
are that are way beyond the
oh sure is that we you know and how far
back in prehistory they are but there's
always some sort of you know connection
through through blood or through
adoption or some other kind of relations
of people connected with each other and
pursuing common tasks and one of the
things that's really important about
families they they have to engage in
some sort of nurturing right I mean if
you think about baby's baby he's in a
way are a great investment but in a way
there is a short-term investment there
terrible investment because they can't
do much of anything and they make noise
and consume resources and so why why
attention focused on protecting them
nurturing them and helping them on their
way
well you know Aristotle see is that
there is in some rings in our nature and
then stoic saw it that way as well if
you read you know the discussions about
our natural familial affection and if
you read the discussions about you know
how how we view our our young we in
terms of sort of a natural impulse that
can natural law for us read Cicero
you'll find out plenty about that or
Senate echo he's got some discussions of
that and so does epictetus these are all
common themes but now how do we get from
there to something that's bigger what
Aristotle calls an echo so house hold an
economic unit well it's through people
living a common life but more than that
and it's more than just feeling a
affection it's the shaping and sort of
communicating and sometimes even
debating about what we call Broyles
Aristotle says that we human beings we
have a perception and communication the
goodest and the unjust the beautiful and
the ugly the advantageous and harmful
the pleasurable and the painful and all
the other moral qualities he says
like and this is again in in politics
book 1 so we've got this this you know
sort of IDE Hill place where we're
connected with these get shaped like our
desires and and our viewpoints on things
are ways in which we deal with other
people we model ourselves after other
people within our family and that's kind
of a nice picture but then there's the
other side is that the way most actually
are I mean if the goal is to like have
that and then like build a society out
of it it's never really happened has it
because most families are pretty screwed
up in one way or another and some of
them are terrible terrible places the
children being in that family then then
being in and certain families and I
think that's a theme all returned to I'm
gonna take a look at some of the
questions first that are coming up
because there's quite a few so daniel
has a good question do I think looking
at how a family operates is a useful
analogy for how a communist society
would operate our social relations and
families aren't predicated on production
or money well sometimes they are so you
know I mentioned there are there are bad
families and or flawed families and that
that happens quite often and I think
within a lot of families people are in
fact value ASIS of what it is that they
produce or provide you know you might
think about parents who so invest
themselves in their children that their
children never get to really have their
own views desires you know like if I
wanted both of my kids to be
philosophers and I said the philosophy
he's really good you need to be on this
path that might not suit them you know
if they're gonna find their way to that
as in some respects they are you know at
different points and and in different
ways they have to find their own way to
that rather than me simply imposing it
upon them and you know a lot of children
are used as sources of
cheap labor I mean think about
restaurants right and how many kids have
worked restaurant jobs and not gotten to
enjoy much of their childhood like their
their classmates because their family
wanted a source of free labor and things
like that go on now can can the family
in in a good sense
ecology for for how communist society
would operate and that my my answer is
perhaps but it would have to be very
carefully done you would have to think
about well what aspects of a family are
transmittable that way and then what
I'll point out one thing that Aristotle
brings up again in politics books want
and also in in the nick of mccanna
ethics later on it's gotten different
sorts of relationships you have to be
treated as fundamentally different or
you wind up with some real problems so a
society you know the relationship
between fellow citizens within a society
or between ruler certain sabji can't be
the same thing as between family members
and when we try try to make it like that
and we we tell each other these lines
like we're all one big happy family
that's usually [ __ ] and somebody's
getting exploited and somebody is
getting suppressed and somebody is
getting a burden somebody else is
getting just fat nearly every time that
that takes place and and and you know
they may not even realize how they're
being exploited in that that process now
you know could we take some things like
talk about mutual affection you know in
a way hey this is what Plato's Republic
which I know people are gonna bring up
is try do with its total reworking of
family notice that Plato doesn't just
say get rid of families altogether the
noble lie that he's telling and all this
eugenics programs and stuff like that is
to produce
something like shed across the entire
society so that if I'm a young man I
look at all the older men is being my
father's or my uncles or other ladies as
being my my mother's or ants or whatever
it is right we have that now can that
really work I I think it would take a
lot of shifting of society in order to
make that that's something effective but
it's a great caution oh they asked a
question that doesn't have innate who
the family what do I think of ordinary
language philosophy I think that you
know when it was being done they
trusting things I like to consign I like
rile there's some interesting thing that
people like ah stand you know P John did
John wisdom I'm a big fan of him as well
but I think that when it was taken as
being like the be-all and end-all a
philosophy it was leaving so much stuff
out you know that in some way is the
read when it's connected with other
people's research programs all right so
another a bunch of other people are
saying paying high as well I'm Gabriel
about the family would I say Socrates
neglected his family in his pursuit of
the divine command he received from god
complex question but the simple answer
is definitely yes I think that Socrates
is and this is one you know there's a
lot of people who look at Socrates and
they're like I want to be like him and
you know the more time that I spend as a
philosopher I don't want to be like
Socrates quite frankly you know uh Dalls
I'd rather be like Cicero or some other
thinkers who seem to have done a bit
better with managing those those sorts
of balances Socrates you know didn't
really spend much time with his family
as far as we can tell
his kids don't appear to have turned out
very well and now you might say well you
know he had Xanthippe and she wasn't a
very to be with so maybe he didn't want
to be home but we know he spent time at
home but he just he did he didn't seem
to spend a lot of time you know coaching
his own virtue that yes in some early
dialogues virtue can't be taught but
definitely in others it seems like it
could be at least in certain respects we
could prepare the rudiments of it you
know he did feel that he had a sort of
divine and command but he interprets it
in a really weird way right so he
doesn't have a divine command saying
spend your time doing philosophy seek
wisdom go around and ask your fellow
citizens you know if they really know
that's all his own interpretation of it
as a matter of fact there was no command
at all in the first place he's merely
given the Socrates as the wisest man in
Greece where there's nobody wiser than
him
and he says hmm I wonder what that could
mean let me go around and start asking
people I'll try to refute the guy so you
know it's a really weird way to try to
follow God's God's rule I don't look at
Socrates is a particularly good example
of a a father you know great example of
a teacher in some respects sample of a
friend but he doesn't seem to me to be
the kind of guy who actually you know
had it going all across here's an
interesting observation from me smiston
men fan Emily when functioning properly
is one of the primordial ways for an
individual to actually make one's self
meaningful yeah
I I think that is it when it's
functioning properly I mean in in many
other respects is something I'll come
back to in a couple minutes
in many other only can really damage us
in terrible ways making us less capable
of dealing with the world or are less
capable of having our own successful on
the side you know later on to deal with
and to build and work with so that when
it is functioning properly
you know Alistair McIntyre in a seminar
that I was in with him he called the
family the first school of desire and I
think that's a great way to think about
the family for better for worse shapes
us helps us figure out who we are this
is my psychoanalysts actually whether
you buy into it or whether you like you
know young as opposed to Freud or
whether you like Lacan you know or
whether you're into this guy or the AK d
and each time is that they're probing
how the FIPS us you know so let me come
back to that and in a bit tow
perturbation here that I think is partly
correct but partly incorrect baby's
equal pension fund before the state took
that well I think some people saw kids
that way if that was the main idea that
and the Stoics would never have written
what they wrote or Aristotle would never
have written what he wrote Plato had
never written with what they wrote
there's a sense in which we nurture
children not because of what we're
actually going to get out of them down
the line because that's a terrible
investment especially in a time of high
Chilean child mortality but because we
feel that we ought to we feel that
there's a good that's being generated
there we respond to the vulnerability of
the child we respond to for for the
child now that's not to say that you
know there aren't some people who are
kind of mercenary
like yeah I'm gonna know somebody to
take care of me and if nine out of ten
of them die at least I'll have this one
to take care of me if I put a big enough
guilt trip on and so he has that but
that seems pretty contingent you know
and there's there's certainly more to it
than that you look down Thomas Miller
what do I make of recent reports
claiming mail for twelve fifty percent
and falling are we being poisoned by the
deep hop lobby so oh I don't know what
male fertility but if T percent means
are you saying fifty percent of the
people are shooting blanks because that
that's what the sentence would seem to
imply I I don't I've never seen any
report claiming that I would be very
surprised if that was the case maybe I
mean that that men just aren't having
sex does mantra down or something like
that
are we being poisoned by the
depopulation Lobby I doubt it if we are
it's a big super me I know I'm not part
of the X I've got two kids myself I mean
we we really we really do have a huge
population on this this earth that has
grown immensely over just the last
hundred years
it's funny when you read old science
fiction and you see that I'm talking
about like wow we're at three billion
and you know when they're projecting
that years and years from now and we're
like well we're at over seven now I
don't see that you know myself I don't
see declining fertility rates as problem
except for the issue of how do you
maintain you know sort of
intergenerational the Social Security
system and things like that well on the
labor system as a whole but but I don't
know much
about that I III don't you know there's
a sort of Lobby out there I guess you
could say oh I don't know it's a one
single force that really does want to
cut back on the population but I don't
know how much how much power they they
have Nathan has a good question here
about and and this is a Peterson
question that for once isn't just what
do you think about Jordan Peterson so
here's a good question
can I get an opinion on the idea of
enforcement agha me as prescribed by
Peterson by a my a socially enforced is
their argument against it or is it just
that it has worked so well I mean the
let's start with the last thing his
enforcement agha me so and let's talk
about enforcement right right and here's
where Jeremy Bentham like then can be
quite quite people forget that Bentham
was not just a moral theorist he was
also a legal theorist and he was a
social theorist thinking about how do
you how do you modify things in society
and how society works so Bentham talks
about sanctions and by this he doesn't
just mean like what we normally talk
about is sanctions penalties he means
also rewards too and he talks about the
difference between a political sanction
call a social sanction so a political
sanction is a law and some sort of means
of enforcing the law and so to have
enforced monogamy which by the way I'm
not for for yeah and we enacted laws
that would be you know legal sanction
right a political sanction we'd have to
settle that politically in some way then
there could be you know a cultural or
social however we want to call it
sanctions where it's social pressure I
would say in a legal system that is
being brought to bear so I see people
having sex outside of marriage and you
you like don't invite them to your party
he's an you
smack him about them and you'd sit next
to them on the soccer you know bench you
know at the game or something like that
okay those are all Oh sort of ways to
bring social pressure where you see
other people to be monogamous you you
wave the carrot in front of them and
like hey you'll be part of our club and
stuff like that and then there's other
sanctions like you know in he talks
about physical sanctions like you know
if you do certain things you get pain if
you do certain things you get pleasure
you know that's what kind of payoff and
he also talked to go to relieve that out
of the purview for for the time being
but these are important ways to think
about how how would it be enforced right
how wouldn't banana some respect
whatever it's gonna be be be enforced
know how does it really work
I'm diva literature if you think that
the Middle Ages was a time of enforced
monogamy and see just how well those
sorts of regimes actually did manage to
control people's sexuality and the
answer is sometimes pretty well a lot of
the times not quite so well at all I
mean even you can even find like monks
and nuns screwing around by the way
cross culturally not just in Western
monasticism but also in eastern
monasticism so you know does it does it
work
does it work for what we have to ask
that question and and what counts is
working and is there an art enforced
monogamy if there is an argument for it
it would have to be of one of two sorts
it could be based on the idea that this
is well there could be three sorts
actually it could be based on the idea
that this is somehow better for society
it leads to more stability aid in order
to continue as as a culture or society
or civilization and there might be an
argument for that but I haven't seen
that makes me think that that even
monogamy as a model is absolutely
sir a let alone force monogamy it's
needed for the well-being of each
individual that either you know if
they're gonna have some sort of intimate
or romantic relationship it needs to be
monogamous and if not they're damaging
themselves or you know hurting hurting
other individual and I don't think
there's a lot of very great arguments
there that don't already make some big
assumptions I mean as a virtue ethicist
I would say that in general sexual
promiscuity is probably bad for you
right but that doesn't mean that that or
by that that everybody else is going to
buy that and there's the issue of well
okay do I I if I'm going to try to push
this idea onto others which is not a bad
idea to push is it really effective for
me to do it sort of in a tie up down way
or should I try to you know end to it in
some sort of way and then you know the
other possibility it could be like well
got and told me that things have to be
this way or else you know the fabric of
society is gonna break down or or
whatever you know any of those those
sorts of things and man you're not going
to get any consensus on that so i see
the whole enforcement agha me thing is
it's an interesting idea for people to
kick around but it's a total non-starter
I mean and we do what we do small
subcultures that that do we have
enforcement agha me and it doesn't
appear that people are particularly more
happy in those cultures than in others
uh you know as a virtue ethicist I place
an emphasis on sort of each person
having to decide to move themselves
towards a better way of being and and I
think that you know although Aristotle's
right that the laws can steer people
towards virtue they only go a certain
amount of the way
all right so here's another question
from amok all right could be that you
want a green card could be that you want
somebody to do you know styling stuff
with it could be salt sorts of prosaic
stuff like that could be that you you've
been dreaming about this day your entire
life because you were raised thinking
that marriage is so so important and
you're lucky enough to find somebody who
might fit the bill and so you you know
you you put them in their tux or their
their wedding gown or whatever it is get
them up there and marry them could be
because you find somebody that you want
to spend the rest of your life with and
you want some way to sort of cement that
bond and you think that for some reason
or another ceremony or legal recognition
it means something could be because
you're a big believer in midge as such
there's there's a myriad of reasons why
people could get married and there's
plenty of reasons why people shouldn't
get married not only is ins that can
apply to many different people but also
specific reasons you can look at some
couples and be like man I know they're
engaged with those people should not get
married you know they depend so some
people are saying the audio and stuff is
messy and laggy not much we can do about
that that's that's an internet issue um
that unfortunately we're stuck with
maybe it's laggy here in Milwaukee could
be our apartment building could be I
don't I don't know about that all right
Gabriel have you read my on 10 on how
parents should educate and raise their
children ago it's been a while since
I've read that if so do you think it's a
good way to expose your children to new
ideas
I don't remember enough about the
particularities of that to comment but I
will say this that exposing your kids to
new ideas in sort of measured doses
and with some context I think is an
important task for parents but that also
means you had a parents who are actually
up to the task
alright so I'm not sure how it's
pronounced burrs son hmm maybe bit off
topic but a big mind to not to want to
marry and form a family hold Ming Tom
movement thoughts on that well I think
that a lot of men who don't want to
marry and have a family
make Thao I think that there's plenty of
them out there saying the pickup artists
you know can community or who just you
know are you know totally oblivious to
what's going on in terms of gender
relations or that that whole discourse
and and are just like maybe saving money
or or not that interested so there's a
lot of other reasons why one might not
want to marry and form a family um some
people might act ma out of you know
damaging for them and say man I I don't
want to impose I don't want to live that
sort of life I don't want to turn into
the person that my dad was or my mom was
or saris the Midtown movement it's kind
of an interesting development right like
that have been around throughout history
there were you know confirmed bachelors
who wore as a cover for for you know
carrying on some some gay relationship
but because they genuinely he just
didn't want to be involved with women
because they saw it actually like a
whole literature out there of people
like that sometimes they're called women
haters so you know and this didn't want
to be bound up with all the the things
that came with with marriage the I think
the modern make table movement which in
large part had it has its origin I'd say
in the whole YouTube community
judging from from where were growth and
development took plan it's more
self-conscious and it's kind of all over
the map
right there's there some like I've done
some interviews with with Marcus guy who
runs the for the metaphysics of mgtow
very philosophically well-informed guy
pretty moderate on some things there are
some things that he's definitely
committed to but he can have a
reasonable conversation about why it
might make sense for a lot of men to you
know put the brakes on romance get
married and not have kids and all that
sort of stuff given like current you
know divorce law regimes or Hawks or any
of those those sorts of things you can
have a reasonable conversation with them
then there's others who are like way
over on an extreme and they're filled
with the red pill Rand they spout all
sorts of stuff that's that's from you
know evolutionary biology and you're
like well really can't have much of a
conversation with these guys mom they're
so committed to to you know a kind of
mishmash of ideologies of them there's
guys in between but I think that you
know good way station for for quite a
few guys who wind up you know getting
burned or something like that if you
think about why I what happens when you
when you kind of pursue romantic
relationships and you still focus on
yourself and your life right maybe you
work on getting your finances in order
they stop eating out and stop buying
stuff and restaurants and stop going to
bars right and suddenly you're
financially solvent for once or you
start working on your body because
you're not spending time in you know
conversations about that that may or may
not lead to dates which may or may not -
all sorts of other stuff right or are
you spend time on on study and and these
things can slowly change a person for
the better for the worst - if they
become arrogant about it but I think a
lot of cases it's it's for the better
and then there's this kind of funny day
and I am
right because they were attractive the
the very women that they're swearing off
and then there's greater temptations so
then they they have to figure out what
they're gonna do about that I think a
lot of guys then leave right but maybe
they leave a little better equipped for
having healthy relationships if they're
just you know in Hanjin they're you know
I mean if you go on a date and you like
start spouting stuff from Ming town
videos man don't expect that date to go
good I guess because who wants it unless
unless you find some somebody who's
really really into that all right so
let's go on which philosopher would be
the best parent I don't know you know I
mean that that's best parent in what
sense and I mean with some of them
didn't I mean sister was a pretty good
parent as far as I can tell but you know
we don't really know that much about a
lot of these people so grass dealer
raising a stoic child asking because of
the example of a tyrant that Marcus
Aurelius is Funko motifs turned out to
be well I don't know that Marcus tried
to raise him to be a stoic child he
certainly did give him tutors but Marcus
didn't get to spend a lot of time with
comodo you know one on one any sort of
meaningful way he's running an empire
and you know Donald Robertson is
somebody who's actually put a lot of
work and thought into this and he's made
a pretty good argument one you know one
reason why commodious didn't get out of
the succession was because realized by
the time that he was starting to see
commodious his character that if he did
like say okay Komodo he's not going to
be the successor I'm designating this
person over here it would lead to
faction in a succession crisis and all
sorts of intrigues and you know you you
can't always soundly you can
automatically shape your kids along the
lines of your favorite philosophy
the stoic got that children will anyway
so you've got to spend a lot of time you
know sort of helping them along and bit
by bit by bit with things that are not
really gonna make sense to them at the
time and there's lots of ways for things
to go go wrong and Marcus himself was
not a perfect guy why do you think he
wrote the meditation though those are a
lot of the things that he needed to be
now does that mean that you can't you
know teach your kids some resilience
techniques they analyze a ssin or remind
themselves about you know how to
prioritize goods or indifference against
each other more you can equip them with
that but you don't dictate that they're
gonna turn out in some great way I mean
you know peer parenting is mats which is
pretty tough to do so all right let me
see just skipped a little bit so I'm
gonna scroll back up to see lakhan's sa
family complexes in the formation of the
individual if so what did you think of
it I don't know I probably have you know
but I don't get a much time to read look
on these days so there was a point where
I just like read everything I could get
my hands on and then you know as I
prepared for like writing essays and
things like that but doesn't doesn't
ring too much of the bell let's go on me
smiston we think and conceptualize love
a lot in terms of the concept of family
for it's a sphere which encloses within
itself a lot of ways that love manifests
itself marriage good friends etc yeah
that's that's true I mean you know the
people who are really fond of saying
there's four kinds of love you know like
CS Lewis or you know all these these
pastors that they pick up on his stuff
and then like well there's a Greek word
for this and the Greek word
for this and the Greek word for that
there is so no familial affection Phil
Astoria is something that that we should
think about and it is somewhat different
from erotic or romantic love or from
friendship but but it's not City can't
have friendship within the family in now
and so who is this what were some of the
reasons you decided to have kids that's
a good question what have you learned
from the experience
well you're involved in a marriage in
any sort of traditional way children are
supposed to hopefully result from that
and so there's that aspect but you know
I've always wanted to have kids of my
own too
and it's interesting you would think
that so I'm adopted right and like a lot
of adopted kids I wanted to know who my
birth parents were I was much more
interested in knowing who my birth
father was then my birth mother and
there's a whole long story there that I
can I can tell it in other places and
people can sort of track that down and I
you know I didn't want to have kids but
but it wasn't so much like to produce
little genetic you know versions of
myself although that's that's sort of it
it's to have kids and then you know do
the sort of things that that you know
maybe yeah my mom and dad had done with
me and to live that common life together
there's something about bringing a new
not just life but person into the world
the person who's growing and changing
and shaping arrows and frustrations and
and setbacks along the way that on the
whole is is Jen you know generally much
more more good there's a
plenitude there yeah and and kids are
you know very surprising to then figure
it out because they are into this sort
of stuff at this age and then they they
find other things that they're they're
really interested in but being able to
form those connections is very and I
think it would have been the same
whether my kids were genetically related
to me or or adopted because I and I have
models for that because my parents when
I say my parents I mean my adoptive
parents loved me and my sister just as
much as anybody he also loved their
birth children and it was the same with
my larger family the Larry's family
where we were never treated as as
different than anybody else because we
were adopted that's part of it what have
I learned from the experience
well I can't mention kids never turn out
even remotely way that you expect them
into charting things from point to point
to point there's there's always
surprises that come up along the way and
some of them are happy surprises and
some of them are unhappiest of
challenges that arise and
disappointments but then there's also
getting to see them grow and and change
and I think that's part of to talk about
a lot by philosophers it's more about
like you know the duties towards
children and then our natural instinct
to help raise them and how you know with
then a house way should be parents and
the children all that but there isn't a
lot of discussion about what it is that
we we see happening with the kids as
they as they grow I think psychologists
have paid more attention to that or
literary figures than philosophers did
[Music]
in the Nicomachean ethics Aristotle says
the family is earlier and more necessary
than the state and politics these teams
as think that state is prior no the
state's not prior I mean in the politics
book one first you have families then
you have images then you have the polis
of the state so that's not that's not
correct at all the state is prior it's
not in a sense of temporal prior
but in that within the polis which you
can translate as political community or
social community we have a greater
capacity to be who we are to grow into
the kind of beings that we are to
flourish then we do who merely within
the family shuttles very clear that the
family antedates the state so all right
I in the line of long term relationships
that's a great question and we could
phrase that in two ways
right a decline in long-term
relationships in terms of like
individual relationships and then is
there a decline in long-term
relationships in Western society and you
could say yes in a way because people
are living longer so they have a longer
amount of time to get sick of each
other's [ __ ] and say let's see let's
divorce longer that you know also the
no-fault divorce laws and and you know
the greater social mobility that we
enjoy asked and not only social mobility
but but spatial mobility and so you know
in the past if you had a husband or wife
that that you didn't get along with that
well it might be difficult to break it
off you'll probably die before too long
you know and then and then you can go
your merry way mortality rates were
higher right long-term relationships in
general in order to sustain one
especially in this day wouldn't a new
developments constantly going in I mean
just think about incorporation of
Technology right it's cell phone you can
have two people who are great with each
other and then this sort of stuff comes
along and one of them becomes addicted
to their phone and can't give the other
person time a day and then you're not
going to sustain a relationship right
well that's the other because they're
both
texting to each other or something along
those lines so you know it takes more to
successfully keep a relationship going
these days then then it may have done in
the past and I think we have less
resources I'm a hole for doing so we
have lots of websites lots of self-help
books we have lots of therapists of all
different stripes out there but I don't
know that that many of that is really
particularly useful for a lot of the
people that are seeking the advice on
them Nicola yes what about the Platonic
view of the family and the Republic so
what is the Platonic view of the family
and the Republic in this ideal city you
get rid of the nuclear family and you
tell them everybody that's coming from
the earth and and then you encourage
this sort of much more how would you put
it I mean there there are there are
anthropological studies that that talk
about particular peoples that are
similar to this where it's not you're
you know just genetic mother and father
that you're supposed to have affection
to but like an entire class of people
and that's you know in a way what's
going on in the Republic is trying to
produce that familial affection towards
everybody within the society so what
about it I mean that's that's cool
keppen but there seem to be a lot of
difficulties it's actually pulling off
something like that and and I do have to
to end at the top of the hour this time
I can't go on as I often do do in in
other sessions let's see what we got
here
so that's on Engels work the origin of
the family's to date that a long long
time since I
so I don't have anything to say about
that
miss me stand a genuine and proper
family as local cassavas love in itself
loving someone as oneself yeah that can
be a part of it I mean loving them as
other is important too so it's not just
like a kind of narcissistic relationship
loving ones as oneself maybe in the
biblical sense of like you know being
you know with the same love that you
would give to yourself okay that that's
good call on where did you go to school
what sparked your interest in philosophy
I mean that's something you can easily
find online what's a Southern Illinois
University I've talked about that whole
sort of back story many many times you
know what sparked my interest
running into interesting texts but but
you can look around in the videos for
that sort of thing
Luco what are some of the best our
glimmer that it's immoral to have
children I don't think there are you
know best arguments I don't buy the
anti-natal list line the you know the
close to I'd say the more reasonable
ones tend to like focus on like the
carrying capacity of our planet or stuff
like that but that's that seems like a
lot of the people that are into
antinatalism they speak in very rational
terms but there's some sort of emotional
thing on there
Marco's family issues such as divorce
are handled in the courts therefore what
readings could you recommend for future
law student that's interested in family
law no I I I don't do that that sort of
stuff I barely get enough time to read
the stuff that I want or read math and I
can tell you that divorce and family law
is different from state to state to
state to state you know butterfly in New
York State why is it here a good
question why is it some people who grew
up in a bad family to turn to a life of
crime or drugs while someone else who
rarely chooses a life in a more positive
of direction so there's a broader
question here people are always asking
is it nature or is it nurture then I say
why not both and also choice and habit
and what you do with things right if you
want a fuller understanding of things
you'd have to incorporate those and then
people are like whoa choice isn't
scientific you know you can't do Studies
on that sort of thing you can't really
in corporate say yes you're right so the
metaphysics of human action is not
something that can be understood solely
in terms of social science or physical
science or anything like that
because that's not the kind of beings
that we are and so what answer could be
well on some level the kid who turned
out okay chose not to allow the
determinants in their their environment
to become complete determinants another
answer could be while they had other
things that you left out of the picture
like a mentor came into the picture also
part of their environment or you know
they they they they saw their father
beating their mother and as opposed to
having the sort of like helplessness
reaction they felt a sense of discussion
you know there's a when we get to these
these sort of cases you have to actually
go into the cases and look at them and
interview people and say okay why did
you turn out differently or anything
along those lines
alright so Mohammed how to start
learning dairy des deconstruction I
don't know
read area I would start with reading
speech and phenomena because it's an
early work and then you're gonna start
moving into other early dairy da stuff
but he'll I I don't know that's that's
you can read all sorts of glosses on it
but some of them may be incorrect so
Gabriel Connor thoughts on the verse in
Luke where Jesus says one who does not
hate there must be a disciple yeah
one of those hard sayings isn't it
that's one of those uh those things
where you want to contextualize it in
with other verses I mean why do you
think it's being sent I mean these are
the things are are they're not to just
provide a lexer no here's the here's the
the code you know but to get us to do
some thinking and probably some some
dialogue about that principled
uncertainty happy to see here all my
antenatal astray are dead unsurprising
where they all all they suppose or he
says life has to be embraced for good or
for ill there's no nothing else for it
and yeah okay III think that's that's
true as well I mean it's not like every
little bit of life automatically is
always gonna be great or anything like
that life does often wind up in
competition with other life but I gotta
say I've never really seen anything in
what you know stuff I've encountered in
antinatalism that I could I could really
take take all that seriously
this was the last thing that I've got
here in the oh here is going up to an up
something Bob that I skipped over being
a fan of it constrain how did you
overcome the problem of expressing love
he says if Sandler doesn't get around to
it but the way that I've already always
seen that is the idea that in or digital
oh okay that's that's his response to
the Luke thing how did I overcome I'm
the problem of expressing love it was
never a problem for me
why that would result from Vidkun Stein
anyway I mean you could even have a
language gamer form of life that it
involved Express couldn't [ __ ] I mean
maybe there's something at MIT
constrained somewhere that I I haven't
seen or or have forgotten about where he
brings up how
it is to express love but I don't I
don't remember that and I think there's
resources admit concern for
understanding expression of love quite
well so I'm not really sure I understand
that that question alright so looks like
I missed some in here Mohammed is
studying philosophy and Germany good or
it's better in America and Britain
depends on what you want you know the
resources you have I don't know ask a
German and ask Britain I'm not over
there here in America we have this an
incredible massive patchwork of over a
thousand maybe two thousand different
colleges and universities states some of
which are private institutions all of
which are you know independent events of
each other there and so you know
studying from exactly in each each place
so I don't know how you would possibly
understand that that let's see if
there's any other things ok so who is
this has a follow-up Vidkun Stein had a
hard time expressing love because you
didn't find it on since you couldn't
express it in totality yeah big deal I
mean you could be a fan of it can shine
and say well it's something that's a
problem with what live content isn't it
right poor poor guy he he got himself
sort of double bind where he couldn't
get out of it but again so what you know
I mean there were there were Vinton
Stein scholars who studied with Vidkun
Stein who picked up on this tick they've
can show him something bang his head
against a wall when he encountered a
problem and they would do that because
they thought that's doing philosophy
no that's a personal tic that's a
problem on his part the the woman who I
studied my Vidkun Chang with Donna
Sommerfeld who unfortunately died years
ago she studied with these second these
second generation Wittgenstein people
and she was like wow they really stopped
so what's important is what's in the
philosophical texts not not just in the
biography of the person suppo me
smithston
three to five hours was a reading
philosophy a good amount in a day yeah I
always a bad cut right or think enough
quite frankly there's not a lot of days
than that happens if you get three to
five hours of reading in a day you're
pretty fortunate that's that's pretty
good that's that's a lot I mean if
you're working a job and you've got like
any sort of you know social life and
you're trying to do other things on the
side that's a good amount of reading I
am now is a big question can the problem
question of you evil be solved sure I
mean there's plenty of resolute I don't
know whether you you buy them there's
not there's no resolution to any
philosophical problem whatsoever that
we'll ever get but that's not the
criterion for whether a problem is
adequately addressed in in philosophy
so yeah it's her knee how do I view Zen
so I think there's two kinds of Zen
right there Zen is actually a taught
practiced you know a real tradition in
Buddhist philosophy and then there's Zen
as people like to depict it and you know
is the big thing back when I was like a
teenager and in my 20s people just do
stupid stuff and call it Zen that's not
Zen it's so so I you know I want to
distinguish between people do method
saying cool things or like sitting in
meditation whatever they think
meditation is on their own and then
actually studying Zen
they you know real school that requires
discipline and I think that the Zen
school is quite interesting I spent
plenty of time you know of course I
don't I don't read the languages that
things are written in so everything's in
translation but I plant spent plenty of
time studying it and trying to wrap my
head around it and you know I respect it
it is as a a tradition I've tried doing
sitting mat it but maybe I'll do it
again in the future who knows all right
here's the last question and ik from
only music have you ever read something
about Portuguese philosophy
no and that's you know they like the
Portuguese language I have a copy of
Moshe Lucia - on my my shelf and I
always had the ambition of someday
learning Portuguese so I but no I
haven't haven't really read any
Portuguese authors other than you know
if you secondary source is unlike
Maurice bloom now other things because I
can kind of puzzle my way through
academic Portuguese the way I can throw
academic Spanish and I am which is not
very well but to some degree but yeah I
haven't really encountered any any
Portuguese authors who have drawn me in
happy to hear about them so great
questions thanks for all of these
questions and comments we thank all of
my patreon supporters for helping to
make this possible you know they're the
ones who I underwrite all of these these
sort of online activities and we'll do
another one of these on Facebook live
later this month so you can watch my
Facebook page for that announcement
which session coming up tomorrow as well
so that you know if you didn't get your
questions answered here all the way I
think I did get to everybody's question
for once
that's a good place to get in on it as
well so everybody have a great afternoon
oonh if you're here over here in this
this atmosphere great evening nights
middle of the night early morning if
you're in other parts of the world